hmm I need a beer
hello hey man sorry I'm running late I'm
just looking for parking right now man I
need a beer I was literally just saying
that hey do you think I'm gonna have a
problem getting in I heard that place
gets packed no you should be fine
there's like literally only one person
here okay cool yeah it's super weird
I've never been at a bar by myself
before I'm just like people watching
like this lady right here is just
literally bawling her eyes out
hey Zach just a little pet peeve of mine
but you shouldn't use the word literally
so loosely because it means that yeah I
fell out I did yeah no but she used to
Zach no more I'm your friend I'm only
trying to help you okay well whatever
make sure that you're wearing something
kind of nice I feel a little
underdressed right Oh is there a dress
code I don't know but this guy just
walked in literally wearing a monkey
suit Zach you have to stop saying
literally okay but he's literally don't
want to hear it Zach you have to break
this habit you sound like a fool well
you need to get here soon because things
literally just got crazy
stop saying literally
it is nothing here I'm laughing so hard
I literally just peed my pants
hey can I get a towel I just have a new
hat you say literally one more time and
I'm gonna hang up oh my gosh I'm
literally dying of embarrassment
readiness you know what Zack I'm not
stopper English all right I'm going home
I literally can't even goodbye that guy
who literally drives me crazy hey check
WebMD this guy is literally dying of a
heart attack after peeing his pants